- All right, man, what's up,
everybody in the Internets
world and whatnot?
This is Vandaveon and Mike.
It's the third season
of our show.
It used to be called
"Critiquer's Corner."
We got a brand-new name.
We're gonna call it
"The Van and Mike Show"
now from now on.
You know, usually what we
used to do on the show
was that we would
critique scenes
from the "Key & Peele" show.
- Stupid.
- But you know what?
That's cool.
We don't need to worry
about that anymore, man.
Over 2 million hits
for our show.
- 2 million hit!
- What's "Key & Peele" got?
Who cares, man?
'Cause we are
Internet phenomenons.
I bet, as soon as I finish
talking today,
y'all gonna have like--
- Blip!
- Like, skid-d-d-d-d-rah!
2 million hits, just like that.
- Bitch.
- We're here
for the people, man.
It's Internet free
for everybody.
- It's like Banksy.
- Like who?
- You know.
- No, I didn't hear
what you said.
- The dude from
the documentary, Banksy.
- Oh, Banksy, right.
This that nigga
that can't nobody see.
He out there somewhere.
He be just drawing,
like, rats on a wall.
- Try not to let it
go to our head.
- Yeah, that's
the other thing.
Say it again, Mike?
- Try not to let success
go to our head.
- Exactly, we don't want
no success
going up to our heads, man.
We get a whole new look
up in here.
We got the double camera.
- Why you got two cameras?
- So we can cut
back and forth
if we want to do something,
like, to get
a different dimension,
like Scorsese.
- It's pointed at me, though.
- It's not--
hey, look, man.
Just look where I'm sitting,
and look where the lens at.
It look like it's pointed--
- I'm not talking about
that one.
I'm talking about that one.
- Camera's definitely
not on you.
It's just got
a wide-angle lens on it.
- You know what else
needs a wide-angle lens?
- What's that?
- My dick.
[laughter]
I thought about that
way, way beforehand.
- I didn't know
what he was gonna say.
Sometimes we gonna be talking
about movies that we be enjoying
and how they could have
utilized dicks.
- Whatever's
in the ether.
- Other agendas on the show
that we gonna try
to get to: politics...
- World news.
- I know I wasn't gonna talk
about "Key & Peele,"
but just got to talk
about "Key & Peele"
for just one second, though.
- "The Substitute 2."
- We watched
"The Substitute Teacher 2,"
which is one of the scenes
that's in the first show
of the third season
of "Key & Peele."
- Shit's funny,
that shit's funny, though.
- It was stupid...
- [snickering]
- But it was funny, though.
But it was straight-up funny.
- Ain't none of you old enough
to go to the damn club!
Ridiculous.
- Mr. Garvey--
- Ah, son of a bitch!
[indistinct shouting]
- "Oh, son of a bitch!"
- Kept waiting
for the dick to come out.
- We have found it funny,
but there wasn't
a dick to be found,
nary a dick to be found.
I thought, when he busted
the clipboard over his knee,
like he had done
in the first one,
what if he had just been
like, zip, whoop...
K'shh!
And broke it over his dick.
- [snickering]
- And broke it over his dick!
Ha-ha!
You missed it, "Key & Peele!"
- Yo.
- That might be
the only critique
we do this year.
Enough about them.
Man, they starting
their third season.
Good for them.
We don't need no TV show.
- That's just a rule.
- So I ain't even concerned
about their show no more, man.
They don't want to hire you
as writers.
They don't want to understand
the recipe for funny,
which is dicks.
- Bitch!
- So you didn't hire us,
and we wanted
to give you the dick secret.
- Dick secret.
- But you don't want it.
That's on you, then.
Fuck you!
- Dick secret's when you
think about dicks,
and then only pleasant dicks
come back to you.
You put positive dicks
out there.
- Only positive dicks
be coming back to you.
[laughter]
See, Mike, man,
he prolific--what's the word?
- Prophylactic.
- He prophylactic--
wait a second.
[laughing]
He got the play on words,
'cause prophylactic
what you put on your dick!
Fuck you, "Key & Peele,"
you missing all the gold.